Hello again!
Nee, das ist so peinlich!
Hallo ihr Lieben!
Wir machen heute Käsekuchen aus dem Glas und zwar No Bake,
also es sind eigentlich die perfekten Komponenten!
Käsekuchen liebe ich über alles, Desserts aus dem Glas sind immer gut
und No Bake gerade im Sommer ist perfekt!
Und das Rezept ist super unkompliziert und ich starte jetzt auch direkt mit unserer Creme.
Oh, jetzt hab ich da voll reingedätscht mit meinem Finger!
Das war übrigens Doppelrahmfrischkäse,
(H: *lacht*)
Genau, nehmt da auf jeden Fall Doppelrahmfrischkäse, natürlich könntet ihr bei Desserts aus dem Glas
auch auf fettarme Varianten zurückgreifen,
aber ich mag den ganz gerne und den süße ich jetzt mit etwas Puderzucker.
Alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben findet ihr in der...?
(H: Infobox!)
Infobox!
So und da gebe ich jetzt noch Quark mit dazu, ich gebe zu: heute mag ich es richtig fettig!
Ich habe hier den 40-prozentigen genommen, ihr könntet auch den 20-prozentigen oder den Magerquark nehmen,
das ist gar kein Thema, könnt ihr komplett austauschen.
So das verrühre ich jetzt aber erst mal miteinander!
(H: Ach die Pfunde, die Pfunde schwitzen wir weg du!)
So, das habe ich jetzt 30sek miteinander verrührt, ihr braucht auch keine Maschine,
Schneebesen reicht vollkommen!
Und jetzt kommen die zwei super Komponenten Vanilleextrakt und Zitronenschalenabrieb.
Ich brauche keinen Zitronensaft, wir brauchen wirklich nur den Abrieb,
daher unbedingt eine Bio Zitrone nehmen damit wir eben nicht die ganzen Spritzerstoffe die da drin sind,
diese ganzen gespritzten Sachen, die später nicht in der Creme haben.
So, schaut euch das mal an! Schaut euch mal diese Vanille-Pünktchen an!
Und die Creme ist jetzt auch schon fertig.
So jetzt habe ich mir die Creme in meinen Spritzbeutel mit großer Lochtülle vorne dran gefüllt.
So hab ich's einfacher, jetzt in die schmalen Gläsern zu kommen
und ich mache das jetzt so:
- ich bin jetzt grad ein bisschen aus der Puste weil wir grad 'ne Fliege gejagt haben -
ich mache das jetzt so: Ich nehme hier Zungenbiskuits, ihr könntet auch - wo habe ich sie? -
diese Eierplätzchen nehmen oder Löffelbiskuits oder allgemein Kekse, die ihr mögt.
(H: Oder, oder, oder!)
Oder, oder, oder!
Und ich mache es jetzt so..
(H: Oder vielleicht Oreos sogar!)
Oder vielleicht Oreos, auch eine gute Idee! Dann würde ich sie aber nicht jetzt hier reintunken
weil ich tunke die Kekse jetzt in die Flüssigkeit von meinen Dosenmandarinen, die ich hier
- also ich hab die Flüssigkeit aufgefangen und die Dosenmandarinen brauchen wir auch gleich.
(H: GIbt ein bisschen Geschmack ab!)
Gibt auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen Geschmack, genau! Und wir verschwenden halt auch nichts.
Eine Sekunde reintunken, jetzt gebe ich sie hier in das Glas rein,
das ist dann quasi unser Boden.
So, jetzt nur zur Hälfte befüllen.
(H: Mandarinen?)
Genau, Mandarinchen und jetzt noch mal Creme.
So und jetzt noch hier so einen Mini Soft Cake einfach hier an die Seite
und das sieht irgendwie aus wie ein Cocktail, finde ich!
(H: Das sieht echt aus wie ein Cocktail!)
Wie ein Cocktail!
Und soll ich euch mal was witziges erzählen? Wie viele Mini Soft Cakes sind in so einer Packung?
Schreibt's jetzt in die Kommentare, genau jetzt!
Und wir haben hier nur noch 4 Stück - plus den und den, 4...6 Stück nur noch übrig!
Wir haben einfach alle aufgefuttert! Gut, dass wir noch eine zweite Packung geholt haben!
(H: Also ich muss echt zugeben: diesmal hab ich die gegessen!)
Also ich kann auch eine ganze Packung alleine weghauen aber Hamza ich hab dich voll angefixt, ne!
(H: Diesmal war ich die Naschkatze oder der Naschkater!)
Der Naschkater! Schlimm!
Gut, dass ich eine zweite habe, ich hol immer eine Backup Packung!
Weil ich weiß wenn wir süßes im Haus haben, dann geht das ganz schnell weg!
(H: Weil du die immer isst!)
Eigentlich ich!
Okay ihr Lieben, das war es auch schon mit dem Rezept, das ging jetzt echt ruck zuck
und das sieht mega mega festlich aus!
(H: Warte!)
Ja?
(H: Wie viele sind rausgekommen? Das ist immer wichtig!)
Acht Stück.
(H: Acht Stück!)
Ganz genau acht Stück! Ihr könnt z.B. auch die Menge jetzt halbieren wenn ihr nur 4 haben möchtet
aber stimmt, das ist echt wichtig!
(H: Voll Diva, ne?)
Ne, ist ja auch so! Also ihr wolltet das auch mal wissen, wie viel rauskommt.
Und ich probiere mal. Klar, man müsste jetzt irgendwie alles probieren weil unten ist der Keks und hier
aber ich gehe jetzt einfach mal hier so rein.
Und dann machen wir den Taste Test!
Sehr frisch!
Schmeckt echt so nach No Bake Cheesecake weil es ist ja auch Frischkäse, es ist Vanille,
es ist Zitronenschalenabrieb...
(H: Und ich will jetzt auch probieren!)
Und der Hamza will auch probieren! Komm, probier auch mal vor der Kamera!
(H: Ne!)
Ne?
(H: Nö!)
Ok dann auf Instagram und dann fügen wir die Szenen ein.
(H: Genau!)
Und ihr müsst uns auf Instagram folgen
wenn ihr's nicht schon längst tut, okay?
Das ist ein Deal, alles klar! So, also ich finds richtig geil. ich werd das auf jeden Fall öfter machen,
vor allem wenn Besuch kommt spontan.
Und euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen! Schreibt mir auch gerne einen Kommentar.
irgendwas, was euch auf'm Herzen liegt!  Hier unten, dann schreiben wir miteinander
und dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten Mal hier auf Kikis Kitchen!
Tschüüss! Und ich hab mich nicht dreckig gemacht!
(H: *mit hoher Stimme* Wo-hoow, du bist schlaaau!)
Ich we-heiß!
(H: *mit hoher Stimme* Ja-ha, das ist voll nervig!)